- I have not received a massage before.
In fact, I don't really
enjoy human contact.
(upbeat music)
- I have not given a massage
to a male friend before.
- I'm comfortable getting a
massage from a male friend.
- This will definitely be weird.
I just hope I give a good massage, though.
- You're breathing on me, dude. What.
- Are you ticklish?
- Yeah, I am ticklish.
- This will be fun.
- Let the games begin.
- Throw me that towel. Let
me lay that across his groin.
- Let's get started.
- How much are you supposed to use?
- The secret to a good oiling is distance.
- Ah, oh God!
- Whoa! Oh my God, you'll
squirt all over me.
Let's do it!
- Oh my.
- Where's that tension at?
Is it in your shoulders?
- I think the tension is between us.
(masseuse laughs)
- So much hair.
- I am glad that you're hairless, though.
I don't know why this seems like
it would be weirder if you had hair.
- Perks of giving a massage
to an Asian guy, I guess.
- It feels like a tarantula
made out of hotdogs
is trying to burrow into
the back of my skull.
- I'm just trying not
to look at your face.
(uncomfortable laughing)
- There is a lot of stress right there.
(pterodactyl-like yelling)
- I'm kind of on cloud nine right now.
This feels kind of great.
- He might just start strangling me.
I think that's every man's fear is that
when another man is
massaging them that their
just going to decide to murder them.
- Really, there's no back massages?
- No.
- I shaved my back for today.
- This is so f***ing weird.
- This is weird.
- Yeah, continue. I didn't say stop.
(uncomfortable laughing)
- I can't take it.
- I don't think so.
- Did you catch the game yesterday?
- Maybe it's just that
I'm dulled to the horror
of what's happening to
me, but I don't hate this.
- Well, we did it.
- I feel very relaxed
now. I feel like an angel.
- I kind of enjoyed giving massages.
- It felt simultaneously comfortable
and uncomfortable at the same time.
- Not as creepy as I expected,
giving a massage to a guy.
- We're massage bros now,
highest level of friendship.
- This is okay. I would do this.
- Very anonym--Yeah, I'd
massage a guy. Why not?
- So, same time next week?
(upbeat music)